thus the foregoing has defined the
nature of the activity of skepticism as
such and the way in which it operates it
exhibits the dialectical movement which
sense certainty perception and the
understanding each is and is also the
unexceptional character of what in the
relationship of Lord and bondsman and
for abstract thinking itself is held to
be a determinate element that
relationship at the same time embraces a
specific mode in which ethical laws too
are present as sovereign commands the
determinations and abstract thinking
however our scientific notions in which
formal content less thinking spreads
itself attaching the notion in fact an a
merely external way to the being
constituting its content and which for
it is independent and holding is valid
only determinate notions even though
these are only pure abstractions
paragraph 203 is in many respects kind
of a retrospective it's connecting up
this section on skepticism to what has
come before not what immediately
preceded it there which is what 202 did
connecting it with stoicism but now with
the the whole of consciousness that
early section and also with the
master-slave dialectic and what the
upshot is from that we're gonna see this
continued in 204 where where Hegel is
going to tell us about why all this
dialectical development matters so much
and how it feeds into skepticism so
let's see first how that fits in before
then you know he does say the foregoing
is to find the nature of the activity of
skepticism as such and the way in which
it operates okay that's that's paragraph
202
that's saying here's what we understand
of skepticism so far good enough right
Lennie says it exhibits the dialectical
movement which said certainty perception
and the understanding is so when we were
going through these earlier sections in
consciousness when we're going through
the first part of the work where it
almost seems like given those and given
the introduction and perhaps the preface
what we're grappling with here is a work
in epistemology perhaps or the genesis
of our ideas or you know we're not quite
sure what we're doing and then there's
going to be this this transition to this
other section that seems a little
arbitrary doesn't it why why did we go
through all that why bother
you know plotting out how we begin with
the immediate and then find out that
it's not quite so immediate that what we
intend and what we use language for
aren't you know exactly the same and we
can distinguish this aspect of this
at all and then I'm going into
perception the grasping of the truth
of something you know why do we need to
go through all that well you could say
well you know censor the culminates and
perception and perception culminates in
the understanding and the understanding
culminates in a self-consciousness so
that's a little point of it that's not
all that's going on there though what
we've learned by looking at the
dialectical movements is not to place
all of our eggs in any particular
epistemological or metaphysical basket
to use a metaphor right or to say it in
another way we've learned that no
particular stopping point is the end of
the dialectic you can always go further
with it and it may turn out that it's
not a simple straight forward
progression although we have to set it
out like that in linear form of the text
it could be that it can be hander around
in different ways but it ends up in the
same place so that what we take to be
sent certainty through a variety of
different tropes doesn't turn out to be
scent certainty at all or what we think
to be perception has a lot more going on
in it right there's a possibility of you
know greater freedom greater play in
this that is is involved in the
dialectic and so scepticism exploits
that we also see in the relationship
between master and slave as he's going
to point out here he says the the
unofficial character of what in the
relationship of Lord and bondsman and
for abstract thinking itself stoicism is
held to be a determinate element right
so what what in this power relation
structuring human society structuring
the development of human consciousness
because remember the slave by countering
fear that shakes them too
foundations and by being put to service
by the master and I'm doing work
externalizing himself into work becomes
fully self conscious skepticism shows
like it says the unsexual character of
the determinant element so the master
has mastered and in many respects
doesn't really matter as such certainly
not and the master is being Jim who
lives in that house up there and he has
all these slaves performing this
particular labor for him
stoicism corrodes that the freedom of
saying no that's not that important it
shows the UH necessity of it is it all
the roads to the master-slave dialectic
well no there was something going out on
there just as there was something going
on here learning about the whole
dialectical movement of what it means
then we didn't grasp in that section so
he says that relationship at the same
time embraces a specific mode in which
ethical laws too are present as
sovereign commands this is going to be
the work this is going to emerge many
times in the course of the phenomenology
this focus on the ethical sphere with
the master and slave the mirror power
relation by itself is rather arbitrary
you could you know we do this thing with
movies like Trading Places right now
that's not a master/slave relationship a
class relationship but you can do that
where you switch them around you say aha
now you're this way I get to be the
master and we find out just how
arbitrary and how unassessed these these
power relations turn out to be in many
respects but this is not quite so
arbitrary it seems
there are ethical laws that come down
the master performs a function that is
not merely that of dominating and
enjoying that could work
the master also provides a kind of
ethics or morality a set of numerous
that are being presented as a sovereign
command as a matter of fact when we look
at societies that are at this sort of
level it's not usually one given master
who does that usually turns out to be
the master
you know the gods or somebody like that
who's giving these and the question that
we're dealing with here that's left
undetermined in this passage what we're
going to see addressed very soon well
what do we make of this we've realized
that this contained all sorts of really
interesting stuff but the dialectical
movements from a skeptical perspective
showed us that we can't trust any of
that perhaps not even of the conclusions
because the conclusions feed into other
ones we found that the master-slave
dialectic also and as you know these
unintentional character to the
determinate elements you know so it's
rather arbitrary as well we can we can
you know by being skeptics sort of tear
it down although we're not actually
affecting the power structure by doing
so what about this does this escape the
scope of the skeptic that's the question
that we want to move into now Hegel is
also say another thing about what's
going on in skepticism he says that the
determination is an abstract thinking
our scientific notions in which here's
the structure it was not that much going
on here
formal content less thinking thinking
that is just sort of a schema let's say
spreads itself attaching to the notion
in fact a merely experiment merely a
certain way to the being constituting
so it says all right this kind of
beginning over here here's the idea or
here's the notion it's doing so late he
says in an external way this is similar
to the schema thism that Hegel was
criticizing earlier on the preface he
says which room is independent and
holding is valid only determinate
notions even though these are only pure
abstractions this is not really that
important at this point to think about
but what the skeptic is is doing in a
positive way it is trying to
reconstitute things and so we'll see if
that actually turns out to be a real
life possibility for them or whether
it's a sterile exercise
dialectic as a negative movement just as
it immediately is at first appears to
consciousness as something which it has
it at its mercy and which does not have
its source in consciousness itself as
skepticism on the other hand it is a
moment of self-consciousness to which it
does not happen that it's truth and
reality vanish without its knowing how
but which in the certainty of its
freedom makes this other which claims to
be real vanish what skepticism causes to
vanish is not only objective reality as
such but its own relationship to it in
which the other is held to be objective
and is established as such and hence to
its perceiving along with firmly
securing what it is in danger of losing
that is sophistry and the truth it has
itself determined and established
through this self-conscious negation it
procures for its own self the certainty
of its freedom generates the experience
of that freedom and thereby raises it to
truth
what vanishes is the determinate element
or the moment of difference which
whatever its mode of being and whatever
its aura sets itself up is something
fixed and immutable it contains no
permanent element and must vanish before
thought because the different is just
this not to be in possession of itself
but to have its essential being only in
another thinking however is the insight
into this nature of the different it is
the negative essence as simple
we've hardly explored in part the nature
and the workings of skepticism and the
two previous paragraphs now into a
before we're going to see how skepticism
functions as a type of agency which it
wasn't realized to be at first it's a
realization on the part of consciousness
of just what consciousness can do as the
negative so actually let me let me put
this here for a moment so I'm going to
be adding a lot to the board as we as we
plow through this Hill starts out this
paragraph by saying that dialectic is a
negative movement right dialectic says
well no there's more to the story let's
also look at this there's you know what
we call determinate negation where we
don't just say no no that's not yet we
say well that's not it because this is
also going on and this and this and this
and now we have to adopt this
perspective over here there's this
constant shift back and forth so
dialectic is a negative movement just as
it immediately is whatever we see an
immediacy what do we get we're supposed
to do look out for some shift that's
going to take place and first appears to
consciousness is something which has in
it and it's mercy and which does not
even source in consciousness itself so
the the skeptic has the same toy the the
seeker the one who wants to grasp the
world the other truth reality these
things over here dialectic may seem as
if it's a way to arrive at it but then
it becomes something like a gatekeeper
or like a thief who takes these things
away and what happens is consciousness
is reaching out through dialectic to try
to grasp the world and dialectic turns
everything on its head and says nope
you don't get it sort of
going into you know a machine and you're
supposed to arrive at some some great
you know thing that you've been desiring
so badly and it plots you down the right
where you start right that's what
happens consciousness then has the
opportunity to stop itself and to remain
in a kind of skepticism that will go
nowhere to say I see we can't really
arrive at anything we can't know
anything at all
oh that's so terrible and that's what
happens with some skeptics that's not
what happens with skepticism itself
yeah that's not why it's an important
shape of consciousness hey bubble goes
on he says and as skepticism there's a
realization on the part of consciousness
that takes place it's a moment to
self-consciousness to which it does not
happen that it's truth in reality vanish
without it's knowing how somewhere over
here and I'm like in a castle or prism
you know worn it off by dialectic rather
it says in the certainty of its freedom
scepticism maze this other which claims
to be real vanish skepticism is
undermining this says what skepticism
causes to vanish is not only objective
reality and such not only this over here
but also its own relations to us
dialectic turns out to have its
negativity only because consciousness is
the negative which employs the dialect
which unfolds the dialectic the
dialectic is something for consciousness
consciousness is not at its mercy
consciousness is grasping things through
the dialectic so as soon as this is this
relation to the other as well as the
other is cause to vanish within this is
this relationship in which the other is
held to be objective and it's
established as such and hence to its
perceiving along with firmly securing
what it is in danger of losing that is
sophistry so perception is being called
into question through dialectic like we
saw right in sense perception in the
sense certainty and in the understanding
we're never really grasping what we
appeared to be wholly grasping there's
always that much more going on and it's
consciousness that through dialectic can
become aware of it
there isn't any independent reality over
here totally away from consciousness and
the dialectic that it is using as its
tool it's also in danger of losing
sophistry that doesn't sound like such a
bad thing right he says hence to its
perceiving along with firmly securing
what it is in danger of losing some
history and the truth it has itself
determined and established so here's
where we get to the part of skepticism
where it starts to also turn inward on
itself
he says through the self-conscious
negation procuress for its own self the
certainty of its freedom by by employing
the dialectic self-consciousness
realizes that it can in fact negate
anything can always take another
perspective because there are other
perspectives there to grasp it just has
to make explicit what is implicitly
there in the logic of the dialectic with
respect to anything else but it can also
turn in this event upon itself they can
turn this on scepticism itself as a mode
of being as a mode of acting so he says
through this self-conscious negation of
procures for its own self the certainty
of its freedom generates the experience
of that proof it's by engaging in
dialectical examination of things then
we realize what our freedom is we have
options we can we can look at things
this way or we can look at them this way
we're also a certain sense honor free
and we're going to talk about that in a
moment as well I just want to plant the
seed for that because part of what we
wanted our freedom is to arrive at truth
and self certainty right but that's
that's that's something you had to come
so he says we were there my memories our
certainty our freedom to truth so what
does vanishing they determine an element
or the moment of difference which
whatever it's motive beating and
whatever the source set itself up is
something fixed and immutable everything
becomes subject to dialectic because is
subject to consciousness so everything
becomes unfixed that doesn't mean that
everything is totally in flux
that's not our experience in the world
but for the skin
anything could be different than it is
there is radical contingency running
through everything we can see that this
is the skeptic in this sense is really
like say David here or to pick a later
philosopher who has a lot of affinities
with that and who is also negative
sensuous lamb chef stuff these these
sorts of realizations of radical
contingency that things could indeed be
otherwise and most likely will indeed
given enough time or shift the vantage
point will indeed be otherwise including
everything that I take to be my self my
consciousness for my consciousness to be
negative for it also to be freedom means
that it cannot remain what it is in any
sort of fixed way forever the dialectic
turns inward on the subject himself as
well as against the world so he says you
know it's there's there's nothing that
sets itself up with something fixed and
immutable it contains no permanent
element and must vanish before a thought
because the difference is just this not
to be possession not to be in possession
of itself but to him it's essential
being only in another what he's telling
the different there is a little bit of
room here difference is relation if you
leave back to Aristotle two categories
if you're familiar with those eras only
wanted to base everything ultimately on
substance for him that's not really
going to be the possibility of the way
that Aristotle envisioned it one of the
categories that Aristotle had was the
Proust T or when we translate as
relation literally pearls tea means in
in conjunction or in can
with her innovation to something else so
I am a son you know from pearls my
father right I am a son my relation to
my father and this jacket is mine it by
being made there's all sorts of other
relations that the light is shining on
me in a certain way and there's other
categories that we could apply like the
light isn't doing the active thing I'm
experiencing a passion Arizona State
this is a very technical we don't need
to get into all this but this this
relationship this relation allottee is
quite an important difference is
revealed as relation and always sort of
subject to being revived he says the
difference is just this not to be in
possession of itself but damn it's
essential being only in another thinking
he says is the insight into this nature
of the difference it is the negative
essence as simple so when we arrive at
the point where we realize the radical
contingency the fact that anything can
be arranged by the dialectic in relation
to something else that we can open our
viewpoint up further that we can
collapse it and Zone in on just this
that that lies within the scope of our
freedom in using our capacities of
thoughts everything becomes at this
stage unmoored
there's nothing that can be totally
relied upon as essential except the
thinking itself thinking is the
essentiality again think back to just
two paragraphs before skepticism is the
realization of that of which stoicism
was only the notion here is where we see
it really being carried out and in the
next paragraph we're going to see how it
falls apart